Before we get started,
let's talk about how to evaluate whether
or not you're ready to take this class.
To take this class, you should answer
yes to all of the following questions.
First, have you already
fulfilled your foundational
requirement for the program?
That's going to give you experience
receiving educational technology, which
should really be all the preparation you
need for the content of this course.
Second, are you
comfortable with writing?
This course is going to involve several
short and a couple long essays, so
to succeed you need to be
comfortable writing essays.
Third, are you comfortable with a course
that's going to evaluate participation
as a first class object in the grading?
Because this course is built
on the discussions and
conversations, we're going to
explicitly evaluate whether or
not you participated in the course.
Fourth, are you comfortable
with taking on a big,
open-ended group project as part
of your work for this class?
Or alternatively,
are you comfortable with taking
on a big project all on your own?
Because the goal of this class is to
produce something that's had an actual
contribution to the educational
technology community,
the scope of the project
will be very large.
So you need to be comfortable with
that kind of project for this course.
Fifth, are you passionate about
education and educational technology?
Do you already have some ideas for
the kinds of tools you might want to
build or research you want to conduct?
Because this class is built
around the project, and
because you'll specify your own project,
it's really important that you be
invested in what you're working on.
And lastly, are you comfortable with a
class that's really built on these big,
open-ended, student-driven projects?
In this class, you're going to propose
your own project, execute it and
deliver it at the end of the semester.
The requirements will be very fuzzy,
the grading will be very informal,
and there's not really a schedule
of what you need to do or watch or
read and when.
And that kind of structure can be
very frustrating for some students.
Now before we move on, let's also talk
about the things that aren't required.
You'll notice that I didn't ask any
questions about programming ability.
And in fact, you can take this class and
you can complete this class without
writing a single line of code by doing
research or user testing or design.
And note that I also didn't ask
if you have experience with
educational technology.
This class is built so
that the only real experience you need
is the experience you've already
gotten in the LMS program.
So you don't really need either
of those things to succeed, but
you do need to answer yes
to the previous questions.